alright guys it finally happened after
months of agonizing speculation a
hundred thieves have finally officially
revealed their csgo roster it's like
christmas came early if you're a
counter-strike fan now the team itself
is pretty hype and a hundred thieves of
being and csgo is just good for the
eSport there was only one little hiccup
the announcement was leaked on Twitter
and nadeshot is kind of pissed we're
gonna talk about all of that
[Music]
all right so since July the csgo world
have been holding our breaths to find
out exactly what roster name shot and
his a hundred thieves brand would sign
for their second go-around at
counter-strike I'm tell you we're
getting a csgo scene
hey John himself was in Berlin for the
recent starladder major apparently
shaking hands talking to players and
trying to put a team together right
there and then and the rumor mill went
nuts now a lot of people including
myself thought that foreign or like a
hundred thieves a cutting-edge content
first organization that gets it nothing
short of a super team in csgo would do
you imagine like Nikko and Kenny s and
simple and device and twists all woosh
together in 100 these jerseys it's a
nice fantasy but that's not exactly what
happened
100 thieves in fact ended up signing the
now-former
renegades roster we have agreed to its
friend so for the now-former renegades
roster so we got a team we got a team
what you're saying is we got a team we
got a team so you're saying there's a
chance of winning a major a lot of them
oh I love some of that look this team is
kind of having a moment this year after
years of winning miners and not much
else
the boys crushed it in Katowice and came
in the semi-finals in Berlin what I'm
trying to say is the trajectory for this
team was already upward this is if you
ask me the perfect time for an org like
a hundred thieves with a ton of cash to
come in and take them to the next level
take them from major semi-finals to
major winners obviously it's no secret
that I personally have a lot of love
with this roster I may have been caught
once or twice being a little biased
towards them on the road back to rounds
down at the moment
guys aren't loud enough where's the
support for these guys now before I
continue gushing about the former
renegades roster there is something we
should touch on first some of you
Twitter addicts out there probably heard
about this announcement before the
actual announcement maybe it was because
of DK's report or maybe it was because
of all the goodbye messages that were
posted to the Renegades Twitter
nadeshot himself was streaming the new
call of duty at the time that this
happened and he did address the matter
pretty candidly he called out renegades
directly and said that they were
coordinating about dropping it the next
day and somehow it got published a day
early he even went as far as to say
quote I'm pissed and what was done was
pure disrespect and quote we'd love to
show you that clip but looks like the
BOD has been deleted whether this was
just purely an accident on the renegade
social media team or something else I
don't know I'm not gonna speculate
nadeshot also took the time to dispel a
rumor that a hundred thieves have been
outbid on the former NRG roster that
ended up going to eg which is a shame
because I feel like that energy roster
at least in part would be perfect for a
hundred thieves I mean content first
brand
mr. content kind of goes together
doesn't it for the record your
information mr. Mertle on the EG
situation is not true we do not get
outbid just saying but let's get back to
the positive news here
I think this re-entry into csgo is
actually just a good thing for the
eSport itself one hundred thieves from
their branding to their content to how
they run their eSports teams is just an
org that gets it they're not one of
these guys doing the same old [ __ ] from
2015 I truly believe that the 100 themes
of the world are going to be part of
what takes csgo
to the next level regardless of whether
this video is a success or failure
pirate rock is still going to continue
in philosophy every single time there's
a major turn
the entire world it's really encouraging
that nadeshot was so eager to get his
board back into CS because the first
time 100 thieves gotten to csgo it
pretty much could not have gone worse
back at the end of 2017 beginning of
2018 100 thieves originally acquired the
old immortal csgo roster they were
enveloped in a scandal after KNG made
some horrible comments on twitter never
played a single map and disbanded after
a month that's a yikes but that was then
and this is now it's obviously a
completely different group of guys and
in terms of the ex renegades players
it's like it's hard enough to love them
I mean you got as ER as the veteran
leader of the squad he's given renegade
so much over the years super happy to
see him in particular get this
opportunity and he is a top lad to boot
but some of it is a [ __ ] you got
Lea's and gratis faction two young
Gunners with great futures in the game
one of which gratis faction has an
incredible mustache which nadeshot
correctly identified as the mark of
greatness jks is a savage see what I did
there and all you old CS fans already
know Jacob who's been a part of a ton of
star-studded rosters of course she got
casada in the coaching position serbian
legend he's played with and coached some
of the better players that this esports
ever seen now the question for 100
thieves here is can this promising
roster that's on the upward trajectory
break into the top three let's say in
the world can they win big and win
consistently and i guess to put it more
pointedly
can they win a major which nadeshot
himself said is the goal obviously the
answer remains to be seen but the theory
is if the boys are having such a great
year on renegades with all the support
the state-of-the-art facilities the
funding that 100 thieves can provide can
they take them from top ten to top three
can this make the difference for this
former renegades roster and guess we'll
see the other factor is aside from
winning actual games of counter-strike
can this roster make great content can
they get clicks on YouTube because after
all that's how you know what a hundred
thieves is about not to take anything
away from their competitiveness
obviously nature's goal is to win is to
get championships but let's be honest
here they are a Content first org in a
lot of ways yeah they already have a
league of Legends team
yeah they obviously take competition
seriously but look they produce hype
clothes they do vlogs they have a
content house see where I'm going with
this right so can the former renegades
roster sell tickets so to speak when it
comes to content I hope so but look if
they start winning majors nobody's gonna
be complaining that as arisen vlogging
enough you ever imagine what the comms
are on renegades Roy ago and B it's
dinky time 8 yet rotate get that
beautiful Molly okay it's just it's full
English that wasn't even Australian that
was just full English I apologize I'm
banned from your country I get it